will i am j julie et bonsoir merci
d'être avec une première réaction à
cette augmentation des capacités
policière de fichage écoutez c'est dans
l'air du temps je crois que c'est une
réponse du politique aux difficultés que
nous avons connues notamment l'année
passée et cette année en cours avec les
problèmes de troubles à l'ordre public
et les difficultés liées aux
manifestations notamment des gilet jaune
il n'y a pas que ça mais c'est
évidemment un des points importants qui
a motivé ces décrets alors vous l'avez
dit un accroissement des possibilités de
fichage parce que premièrement ces
fichiers vont être consultables par les
services de police les services de
gendarmerie puis pour le troisième par
les services administratifs dans le kate
dans le cas de pardon des enquêtes dites
administratives qui peuvent être
conduites par un certain nombre
d'administrations donc une possibilité
pour un grand nombre de services
policiers gendarmes et administratifs de
d'avoir accès à ses fichiers là et ça on
le verra peut-être tout à l'heure mais
c'est une évolution importante parce qu'
un certain nombre de données était déjà
fiché par l'état dans le cadre d'autres
fichiers notamment fameux fichier des
renseignements généraux qui est gérée
par un décret anciens de 1991
donc là la nouveauté sait déjà qu'un
grand nombre de services vont pouvoir
avoir accès à des fichiers qui
d'habitude lorsqu'il comportait des
mentions dites sensibles étaient
réservées à des services plus
spécifiques et notamment à des services
de renseignement la deuxième chose qui
caractérise cet accroissement vous
l'avez rappelé c'est le fait qu'on va
pouvoir faire rentrer dans ce fichier
un certain nombre de données qui n'y
figuraient pas avant ce ne pouvait pas
figurer dans dans l'ancêtre de ces
fichiers là à savoir qu'on va pouvoir
maintenant faire figurer des données
sensibles concernant la santé dans
certaines circonstances concernant les
opinions politiques concernant les
orientations idéologiques religieuses et
même concernant l'orientation sexuelle
donc ça ce sont des choses qui pourront
être conseillés
ces informations sont vraiment
nécessaires pour le maintien de l'ordre
public la santé les opinions politiques
religieuses
voilà j'y venais il y à une nécessité
tout de même que ces données là soit
articulé à une situation de menace pour
l'ordre public alors ce n'est plus le
terme que l'on retrouve dans ces décrets
là parce que on a évolué de l'ordre
public vers les notions de sécurité
publique
il faut que les personnes sur lesquelles
le fichier va porter représente un
danger puisse porter atteinte à la
sécurité publique à la sûreté de l'état
c'est le deuxième terme
ou alors et c'est un des termes qui fait
le plus débat puisse porter atteinte aux
institutions de la république ou à
l'intégrité du territoire et donc il ya
là une conception assez large dans
laquelle non on ne sait pas très bien ce
qu'on va pouvoir trouver exactement de
menaces de danger pour l'ordre public et
pour la sécurité publique et il faudra
pour que ces données dites sensibles
soient consignées et bien qu'elle soit
en relation avec des gens qui présentent
ce type de menace ensuite il faudra
regarder au cas par cas et lapine il
pourra tout de même exercer un contrôle
a posteriori sur le fait que ce qui va
être consignées présente une utilité en
relation avec les risques que je viens
d'évoquer
eu égard à la sécurité justement la cnil
a fait plusieurs mises en garde d'un
déjà ce que vous vous partagez ces
est ce qu'il ya un risque sur la liberté
individuelle des personnes leur vie
privée alors absolument dans l'avis de
la cnil
il y à une première chose qui frappe et
qui frappe un peu dans deux sens
d'ailleurs la cnil relève qu' il ya
certaines choses qui doivent peut-être
être revue ou surveiller notamment
concernant les interconnexions de ce
fichier avec d'autres notamment
concernant la façon avec laquelle les
informations vont être récoltés mais
indique aussi que il est d'une certaine
façon peut être positif que des
pratiques qui existaient avant soit
régularisée et ça c'est tout de même
assez inquiétant ça donne l'idée que la
récolte
parce que c'est quand même le bon terme
de toutes ces informations sensibles et
bien été déjà pratiqué avant je les
mentionnaient tout à l'heure dans ce
fichier notamment des rg mais peut-être
dans d'autres types de fichiers le monde
du renseignement et le monde du droit
vis-à-vis des fichiers est un monde qui
parfois est assez obscures il y à un
certain nombre de fichiers sur lesquels
on sait rien ou quasiment rien parce que
les bases légales qui déterminent ce que
ce sont ces fichiers ce qu'on peut en
faire
les décrets en l'occurrence ne sont pas
publiés donc la cnil a émis un certain
nombre en effet d'avis qu'ils ne
contraigne pas d'ailleurs le
gouvernement qui ont valeur consultative
et on verra ensuite s'il y a des
contrôles qui sont effectués puis on
verra aussi parce que sans doute il va y
avoir des actions de contestation de la
régularité de ces décrets devant les
juridictions administratives in fine et
peut-être devant le conseil d'état
voire même devant des juridictions
internationales ensuite cour européenne
des droits de l'homme cge cour de
justice de l'union européenne et on
verra dans un premier temps sans doute
ce que dit le conseil d'état on peut
rappeler que le conseil d'état en mai a
annulé un décret qui permettait à la
préfecture de police notamment de filmer
avec des drones la fois le public et le
conseil d'état a annulé le décret qui
permettait cela on verra ce que les
juridictions 10
julie avocat spécialiste du droit pénal
et des droits de l'homme merci à vous